most people believe that there is one
way that the body responds to stress and
everyone's heard the fight-or-flight
response but actually turns out that
that's just one way that the body and
brain can respond to a stressful
circumstance and it's often not a very
helpful way to respond to a stressful
circumstances which you really want to
rise the challenge and perform your bass
where it's really not about survival
mode and it turns out the brain in the
body actually has another way of
responding to these kind of high-stakes
challenges you know whether it's an
important negotiation or you have to
give a speech or an athletic competition
those moments where you really want to
show up and do your best and that other
way of responding to stress is called a
challenge response that it's a way for
your brain and body to give you maximum
focus attention and energy and it's
physically different than the sort of
the fight-or-flight response that we
have when we feel deeply threatened by a
stressful situation when you have a
threat response you know your body and
brain are shifting into the state that
is really the sort of the classic
association with the harmful stress
response it's going to make you more
likely to choke under pressure it's
going to feel more like dread or
overwhelm when you have a challenge
response the brain and body actually
shift into a state that gives you more
access to your resources your heart
might still be pounding but your blood
vessels are going to relax and open up
so you get more blood flow to your
muscles into your brain your brain
shifts into a state it's actually better
at paying attention to everything in
your environment rather than sort of
being laser focused like you might be in
a fight-or-flight response on what's
going wrong or what's you know what's
dangerous when you have a challenge
response all of your senses open to all
the information that's available to you
which means you're basically smarter
under stress and researchers have gotten
really interested in figuring out how do
you get people to shift from a threat
response into a challenge response
because unless your life is on the line
in some sort of crazy emergency
situation it's going to be better for
you to have a challenge response than a
threat response you'll perform better
and that's been shown in situations
ranging from people performing surgery
to athletes on the field
it's taking difficult exams that when
you have a challenge response you just
do better and it seems like one of the
best ways to shift from a threat
response to a challenge response is
actually to view your own stress
response as a resource you know the
reason that many people have a threat
response in a stressful situation is
that the very first signs of anxiety
when they notice some sweat on their
brow or they're starting to feel their
heart pound they think oh I'm about to
blow it and they turn their attention to
trying to calm down we're trying to
suppress whatever stress is arising and
research originally coming out of
Harvard University has shown that when
people say okay I'm stressed out I feel
stress happening right now and that's a
resource that stress can actually help
me do better it actually changes the
physiology of the stress response from
threat to challenge and it helps people
perform better whether they're giving a
talk in public whether they are engaging
in a business negotiation whether there
are student taking an exam across many
scenarios literally just embracing your
own stress energy arousal or anxiety can
transform what's happening in your brain
and body to really help you rise to the
challenge